and you know one of the things that Carl
Jung pointed out was that he had this
idea that when science that that LP you
know alchemy is the root of science in
some sense it's this dreamlike substrate
out of which science emerged and but
alchemy was a kind of a weird add
mixture of religious thinking and
scientific thinking because those two
things hadn't been differentiated back
when there were alchemists and Jung
believed that what had happened in in
Europe at least first was that the
scientific end of alchemy blew up and
expanded at an exponential rate and that
led to this advanced technological
civilization that we have but that the
moral dimension that was embedded in the
religious symbolism didn't develop at
all and so we're in this unstable
situation where were far more
technologically proficient than we are
wise and that that's actually a big
problem because obviously the more
powerful the tools you generate the more
intelligent ethically you better be or
things are going to really are going to
go to hell in a handbasket very very
rapidly you know I had this thought I
think I shared it a little bit last
night that you know in the next five
years six years we're gonna develop
pretty viciously intelligent AI systems
and that's already happening you know I
mean they're monitoring YouTube and
they're monitoring Facebook and they're
monitoring Google and they're trying to
make ethical decisions these AI systems
and the problem is is that the ethical
presuppositions of the programmers are
being embedded into the infrastructure
of the net and that's a hell of a thing
to think because it means that for
better or worse we're building automated
intelligences that reflect our own
morality and we better be very careful
about what our morality is if we're
going to automate it because automated
systems are incredibly powerful so so
that's that's kind of that's where we're
at at least to some degree in terms of
the new technological transformations
with in in communication technology you
know it puts each of us at the at the
center of a wide web of connections and
makes the consequences of our moral
decisions much more immediately manifest
to each of us